Getting ready for Black Friday requires months of planning.
Leadership meetings and getting every single point from where guests walk in,...
...to where every single item will be in our store.
And then there's tons of communication down to every single team member,...
...so that when guests come in for that magical Black Friday holiday,...
...it runs nice and smooth and they leave with a smile.
Black Friday isn't just magical for guests.
Black Friday is also magical for the team here at Target as well.
In fact, one of our yearly traditions is everybody brings in a Thanksgiving recipe,...
...and we all sit on Black Friday and have a family meal.
That's how we celebrate our Black Friday holiday as a team here at Target.
Black Friday takes a lot of prep.
Prep for the store, prep for the team and of course, prep for the guests.
But I can't do that without my trusted megaphone.
Let's get started with the wave!
One, two, three!